so
tell me what advice did they give you
well
i have the best advice for women in
business get your [ __ ] ass up and
work it seems like nobody wants to work
these days so you just if you put in the
work you will see results
you have to have a lot of passion for
what you're doing and it's totally true
the ones that are successful love what
they did so they could persevere part of
that is that you help them grow some
teeth so that they can go home and have
that fight with their husband that they
should have had 25 years ago work like
hell i mean just have to put in you know
80 hour 800 hour weeks every day if you
also happen to be human alive and living
on earth chances are you and you both
have been often given sometimes
unsolicited shitty albeit well-meaning
life advice and so today i thought it
would be quite interesting to break down
some of the life advice which is super
popular but i'm very very glad that i
stopped taking and sometimes i've been
doing the exact opposite of what i've
been told and
it's worked out better for me so i
thought it might be quite interesting to
chat about these things today and let's
jump straight into it number one is a
bit of a controversial opinion and
something i feel quite passionately
about but this is the view that you
should work harder so you can get what
you deserve i feel like as a society we
are obsessed with kind of the american
dream and building something from
absolutely nothing from the great gatsby
to kylie jenner we are absolutely
obsessed with these stories of self-made
billionaires and millionaires this
absolute desire and fascination for
success leads us to crave a world which
is quite meritocratic which means that
everyone will get what they deserve they
will get the results of the work that
they attend and this leads to some
celebrities saying that the secret to
success is just to get your
and work now i have a huge issue with
this view that we live in in america
society where people get what they
deserve because even though on the
surface it sounds absolutely beautiful
and happy that everyone would put the
work in and get amazing results but one
i think that this is absolutely
impossible and two i think that
personally when i thought that this was
the case i had a much worse experience
of life and work in general for my
personal view the equation of putting in
the work and getting results looks very
very different to this mainstream elon
musk view of if you're just doing 40
hours you should be doing 100 hours
because your competition is doing 100
and that's where they're succeeding the
people that i've seen succeed have not
succeeded because necessarily they've
put in more work they've succeeded
because of other reasons so when it
comes to formulas for success in my
opinion just five percent of it is this
hard work that everyone loves to speak
of this is kind of during those 100
hours when other people are doing 40.
this is staying up all night this is
grinding this is working multiple jobs
this is being obsessive over details
this is just learning as much as you can
growing as much as you can waking up the
earliest office in the office first at
the office last this is this grind
hustle culture that everyone likes to
talk about i think that this is
responsible for at most five percent of
people's results in general just my
opinion i think the next 15 are the less
sexy things that we talk about and in
this 15 would say things like where we
come from so our ethnic background our
gender our age the way that we look our
potential neurodivergence the way that
we think the unfair advantages that we
have at home are our parents
millionaires are we rich did we have to
do part-time jobs while we were studying
did we even have to study at all were we
given work so these sort of unfair
things that people may or may not have
based on their current circumstances or
their life circumstances i think affect
a lot more than the work that people do
the results of what they get the next 80
and the biggest thing that affects your
results in life in my opinion is just
complete random look this is things like
how the person who interviewed you had
lunch yet or what's their mood like that
day did they get divorced last night
because you don't know these things are
happening all the time in the background
and we just don't know what's going on
but they affect our results so much for
example if you think this is a true
there are studies that found that judges
are a lot harsher with their verdicts
before lunch than they are after lunch
these things affect the results of our
actions and the outcomes of the things
that we apply for in life if someone who
was amazing dropped out of the lineup
for the interview you might get a job
that you got very lucky to get not
because you worked so hard but because
of that and also because someone else
dropped out so all these random things
the people that we run into potentially
sometimes we're in the right place at
the right time or in the wrong place at
the wrong time all of this complete
chaos and randomness in the universe in
our and our lives i think is responsible
for so much more in the result of our
success than anything else and i think
having this view that i will not get
what i deserve but i will put in
whatever work that i do and what i will
get will be something completely random
because only five percent of it in my
opinion is dependent on my work and 95
of it is just dependent on life and
things that i have little to no control
over that means that i can be a lot more
humble and a lot more kind of calm
whenever i get something nice i think
we've gotten somewhere with mentioning
unfair advantages and i think we
recognized this even when we were
younger of saying well you know he has
it so easy because his parents are so
nice to him or because his parents give
them so much money we recognize this but
i think we ignore it a lot more as we
get older and also i think there's this
defense mechanism to try to see our
society as not having any inbuilt issues
and biases which i mean to some extent
it kind of does so i think these do play
a huge role in the results that we get
but also very importantly why does no
one just mention luck luck is just such
a huge thing where you're born who
you're born to what happens to you in
your life what kind of neural
connections you get what environment you
have the emotional intellectual
financial support that you get
throughout the life all of these luck
factors set you up for so much that we
just completely neglect and we blame
everything on ourselves or we attribute
all our results to ourselves when this
is definitely not the case so i'm jenny
not trying to bash people who work very
hard i'm one of those people i work over
100 hours a week consistently almost
like for the last at least five six
years of my life i put the work in i
think as much as i can but i'm not
attributing my results to that work i'm
attributing my results to that
randomness and i get this kind of cringe
inside me sometimes when i hear people
say that oh you should just work harder
everyone can have a side hustle everyone
can succeed everyone can do what i've
done when i hear people saying this i
just wish they would be able to say it
honestly to someone who is an immigrant
in a foreign country where they don't
speak the language properly when they
have three or four kids waiting for them
at home when they have to work so much
already i think just telling them that
oh you can be as fit as i am or as
healthy as i am or as successful as i am
if only you worked as much i think is
absolutely ridiculous and it completely
completely ignores the context and the
luck that is prevalent in every single
situation that we are ever in so i feel
super passionately against work hard
because you're going to get results my
attitude on this is work hard you will
get something completely random because
it's just dependent on your luck and
whatever happens to you but i think you
should just work hard anyway and the
reason you work is not so that you get
what you deserve the reason that i work
for example is because one i have to
because i have to pay rent and be a
functional member of society so i work
because one i have to and two i work
because it's kind of fun you get used to
it if you're lucky enough that
situations are not too bad or if you try
to help those situations along a bit you
can just get to a place where some of
you the work that you do is enjoyable
and that's fine i know that this is a
topic that i feel quite passionate about
but honestly i think it's also spending
so much time in hospital and seeing
situations that people are in that gets
me really really annoyed whenever i hear
this i got here because i worked hard
and you can do it too which i just don't
think is the case in every single
situation having said that put in the
work because it's fun but not because
you're going to get what other people
got because you might get less you might
get more but just to be mad or annoyed
either way and learning to accept
whatever happens to me in life i feel is
a great outcome from this so yeah that's
huge rant number one over and we're
moving on to point number two which is
the view of you need thick skin in order
to succeed in life or in order to make
it your way through life now i've seen
thick skin and being strong praised so
much and i used to genuinely strongly
believe this myself i always thought
that the thicker skin i was and the more
i let problems bounce off me the better
i would be in society and because i'm
quite unemotional and i've been quite a
vulnerable person i think in the past i
used to really really want to get to the
stage in life where i was like nothing
is going to affect me one day i'm going
to be so thick-skinned anyone can say
anything i'm just going to be so strong
and it's not going to affect me in any
shape or form and i felt so bad for
myself at the time going like oh why am
i so vulnerable why can't i not be like
these other strong people i don't think
this is true i don't think having thick
skin is a good thing i think it's
actually really really bad because if we
break it down essentially what having
thick skin means is that people can say
bad things to you or bad things can
happen in your life and you just don't
let it go through you just completely
avoid it because you are so strong that
you you don't need this nothing will
penetrate this is i think completely
impossible and not the right attitude to
have because it doesn't address at all
your internal world instead of having
thick skin i think you should actually
have quite soft skin but you should have
a very strong core having a strong core
means having strong self beliefs and a
strong support system internally and
potentially externally to help you
navigate life rather than trying to
avoid things or deflect things that just
don't suit your worldview so for example
if someone were to bully me or tell me
that oh elizabeth you're so ugly or
you're so nerdy or um you're so boring
in the past this might have generally
affected me a lot and i don't think this
was because i didn't have thick skin i
think this was because i just had a very
bad internal world and i strongly
believe those things myself so once they
got through they would completely take
over and i would have really bad
reactions to this which would be i would
be super depressed or i would cry or i
would break down or it would greatly
affect my life for a month or something
like this but at the time i was
completely not addressing these internal
feelings i was trying to shut everything
off and say the world sometimes says
these things they're not true i just
need to ignore them and move forward
this is a very bad attitude to have i
think the reason that these were
affecting me was not because i was
listening to them or letting them get
through was because they were
reaffirming a belief that i had myself
so rather than working on my thick skin
and ignoring people i should have been
working at the time on my internal state
and the recommendation that i would give
now is to kind of sit with that pain
internally and fully fully lean into it
reflect on what is this triggering in me
what am i believing do i actually
believe that i am unworthy and unlovable
and ugly and awful do i actually believe
these things because if i do i need to
address those i don't need to start
ignoring them because those beliefs will
always remain there unless they're
addressed we even if we don't
consciously do things we will live our
life in a way that affirms these beliefs
if we internally do i think the most
healing and curing thing that i've done
in my life is not build a thick skin
which i did have at some point but then
build a stronger core and surround
myself with people who i love with
people who genuinely care for me with
people who i can see show me that i am a
worthy person and that has helped me and
cured me so much more than ignoring my
problems because no matter how much you
ignore one day something will get
through and if you don't have that
strong core you're not going to be able
to deal with it so i would say yes we
pick up maladaptive coping mechanisms
throughout our life yes our skin will
naturally get thicker throughout our
life as we stop caring about things but
one thing that doesn't naturally happen
but we need to intentionally do is
develop our core develop stronger core
beliefs a stronger support system
healthier views of yourself and this is
a much better way to approach the world
and approach your life than just
ignoring things and nevas has something
beautiful to this effect which is
everyone seems to think that the only
way to get peace is to solve external
problems but there are unlimited
external problems you can only resolve
inner problems and this view of focusing
mostly on your inner beliefs and your
core self i think is a much healthier
way to approach life and leads to much
happier results in the long term at
least in my experience the next advice i
no longer agree with is the view that
you should trust yourself because you
always know best and what's right for
you
i don't i just don't i have often
conflicting ideas i often have arguments
in my mind when i can't make a decision
i will have an argument with two
different sides of me who do i trust i
make really bad decisions i'm the only
person who's been telling myself what to
do what to date who to be with what to
what degree to study what job to take
what to say to people very often this
advice has been absolutely awful so why
should i trust myself blindly also i
change i change so much i'm a completely
different person who i used to be how
can i say that i am consistently and at
every point trustworthy if very often i
think complete opposite things that i
have thought before richard feynman very
famously said the first principle is
that you must not fool yourself and you
are the easiest person to fool even
criminals always think that they are
right everyone thinks that we are right
this is why we have juries and law and
all of these different things obviously
someone sometimes has to not be right
and that person sometimes is me so i
think having a more broader view of
questioning myself whether i am right at
times or whether i'm making the right
decisions or whether i should trust my
instincts i lost my mind a few months
ago and thought that i should leave
medicine because i don't want to do this
anymore i should not have trusted myself
which i'm glad i didn't do so from now
on i keep quite an open mind and a
broader view of any instinct that i get
maybe shouldn't believe this maybe need
to think of the fact that elizabeth has
quite a poor track record in decision
making regarding herself so let's be a
bit more open-minded with this and no i
am not always right because no one is
and i should not always trust myself of
course dangerous situations some caveats
here yes trust your gut instinct um in
those cases but with big rational
reasonable decisions trust yourself i
think a lot less the next life advice
i'm glad i didn't take is a tiny one but
it is that you shouldn't read at night
because you will damage your eyesight
this is not true i was so scared of this
as a child for absolutely no reason now
given that i have really bad eyesight
and i always have contacts in because i
wouldn't be able to see my hand clearly
over here without them
i actually don't think that damage was
caused by reading and even reading in
low light or reading for very long
periods of time can strain your eyes and
can make them quite tired it won't
actually damage them and the last view
is that if you're not enjoying something
or you're not overly passionate about it
then it's just not the right thing for
you this grinds my gears so much because
it's been absolute torture for me this
view elon musk says the same thing so
he'd said people should pursue what
they're passionate about that will make
them happier than pretty much anything
else great advice elon what about the
fact that i'm not passionate about one
specific thing what am i going to do the
amount of hours that i have spent trying
to go through all the alternatives every
time that i've kind of googled jobs
careers and gone through the whole list
and thinking putting myself in that
position and going would i be happy as
an architect or would it be happy as a
movie director would i be happy as a
painter i like these things i like
painting i like drawing i like medicine
i like youtube i like consulting i like
teaching i like all these things i'm not
genuinely passionate exclusively about
any single one of them it will just
change all the time and it's so
frustrating to feel that i'm never going
to be successful because i don't have
one strong passion and this is much more
damaging because it kind of implies that
you should be enjoying what you're doing
and that means that you're passionate
about this thing this is not true we do
not enjoy the things that we do all the
time for example michelangelo complained
so much that his back hurts when he was
painting he hated it it was physical
torture i've read shoe dog and the guy
who founded nike was obviously so
obsessed about his brand and reading
this book everything that i was seeing
he was just complaining he was in pain
he was angry he couldn't sleep he was
frustrated he was having issues with his
wife all of his jobs and everything he
was doing was so frustrating i thought
this sounds more like my work than it
sounds someone who's chasing their dream
chasing your dreams does not always look
like fun and this false expectation that
once you've found that secret thing that
you like you're suddenly the skies are
going to open and you're going to
realize and you're going to be so happy
for the rest of eternity is just not
true and also if you don't have that one
strong passion that's also absolutely
fine you can just work on multiple
things in the meantime and figure it out
later it doesn't mean that you're not
going to be successful quote unquote or
that you even need to be successful or
that if you're not enjoying something
it's just not right for you so on top of
that if she's been raised by strict
parents like i was for example i was
never allowed to do what i wanted to do
when i was younger i was made to do
other things and suddenly you're an
adult and you can make your own choices
and you have to figure out what you like
because how am i going to learn to do
what i like but i've never been allowed
to do this before it's absolutely
ridiculous like putting it on someone
immediately yeah you're free now you can
be whatever you want what are you
passionate about come on become
excellent at it let's do it that just
doesn't happen this is completely crazy
so i think give yourself time you're
probably going to figure it out or
you're never going to figure it out but
if you're calm with it if you're
genuinely approaching things from
curiosity and from trying to get better
at them and trying to enjoy the moment
you're going to have a good time overall
potentially just as much or even more of
a good time as you would have had if
you're working on one singular passion
you don't need to be particularly
excellent and the best in the world at
one thing in order to be happy you can
be average at five different things and
you will be so much happier in very many
ways so i would say love ignoring this
advice whenever someone says pick one
thing stick to it otherwise you're never
going to get anywhere nah screw that
that's not the case if you're in the
same boat as me and you have no idea
which path to taking that for what's
your one main passion but you want to
keep your options open for multiple
things one thing that i would generally
recommend is to put a name on these
things save them somewhere and maybe
they will become relevant at some point
in your life one thing that i would very
very strongly recommend that you do in
the meantime is buy a website with the
name of that project because you never
know when you might actually need it and
when this comes to version but one year
after starting my podcast i only got
reminded to set up a website for it from
hover which i'm very kindly sponsoring
this video in just a few seconds with
hover you can buy the domain for any
website that you think you might need to
set up in the future and i really really
would recommend just keeping these in
the bank because for me for example it
only costs 10 pounds and it's a
ridiculously cheap kind of guarantee or
push to make yourself do things in the
future also what i would recommend for
this is potentially buying one for a
friend or someone that you like or
someone who has had this little project
that they've been considering doing they
only cost five to ten pounds so they're
quite affordable and it's such a good
way to show support and to push someone
along this success journey so yes
there'll be a link for hover somewhere
in the description but otherwise if you
made it so far thank you so much for
spending this time with me i hope you
have a wonderful rest of your day be
kind to yourself and others and don't
believe everything you think thanks bye